god of war ragnarok collectors editions
are finally on sale but can you get your
hands on one plus more stuff to buy with
a new secret lab gaming chair and stray
merch for your cat all this and more on
today's gamespot news
earlier today the collectors and nyotna
editions of god of war ragnarok went on
sale at various retailers but in
traditional limited edition fashion it
seems like they've sold out fast while
inventory has fluctuated across various
retailers many would-be purchasers are
reporting that they're unable to acquire
the highly coveted physical collections
of course where there's thunder there's
lightning aka resellers with listings of
the most premium iona edition posted for
hundreds of dollars more already on ebay
thinking of putting down the money on
one of the two deluxe releases here's
what you need to know the collector's
edition retails for 200
including a 16 inch replica of thor's
hammer mjolnir dwarven dice veneer
carvings and a steelbook case the 260
dollar yotena edition includes all of
that although the dice are slightly
different plus a seven inch vinyl of the
game's soundtrack a cloth map a ring and
a pin set both versions include the same
digital in-game cosmetics but while they
both have a steelbook case the copy of
the game provided is a digital one if
you wish to purchase either the
collector's edition or jonah edition we
heavily advise you to not go with a
reseller and try your luck with an
official retailer god of war speed to
you if you find yourself out of luck
with that and you have money burning a
hole in your pocket perhaps a new gaming
chair will scratch your retail therapy
itch themed around assassin's creed for
your asses need secret lab has partnered
with ubisoft to create this limited
edition gaming chair for the series 15th
anniversary a titan evo model which
gamespot named best gaming chair of 2022
the white red and gray seat is adorned
with a spherical diagram on the back
detailing the evolution of the
assassin's creed logo and if you're
looking to do a full upgrade of your
gaming space secret lab is also
producing an assassin's creed version of
its magnus desk which is adorned with
numerous magnets to hold things in place
such as your cable management system and
desk mat ubisoft is celebrating the 15th
anniversary of assassin's creed all year
long with in-game events and new
cosmetics for valhalla and an upcoming
future of the franchise presentation
happening in september but maybe you
don't want to spend that money on
yourself and instead your feline friend
upcoming cyberpunk puzzle platformer
stray where you play as a cat and is
launching as a part of the new
playstation plus next week will have
some cat related items available for
sale publisher annapurna has
collaborated with travelcat to release a
stray themed limited edition cat travel
backpack and harness it's gaming merch
for your cat that is to say if you can
get your cat into the bag which if it's
my cat is just it's just never gonna
happen retailing for 140 dollars if you
think that's too much to spend on your
furry companion you can settle for the
harness and leash at 40 a replica of the
one worn by the protagonist in the game
and that's it for today's and this
week's gamespot news devante will be
your host next week for more details on
all the awesome things you can buy make
sure to head to gamespot.com
[Music]